you know darn well that every nut in  America is here today now that's not my  fault  I see they're here because he's here and  vice versa  chief bacon knows dr. King is him  because my late husband and I wrote to  him on behalf of the Negro citizens of  this community a community that we  helped build without backs and our  Barents and we told him of our situation  here about organizing here and we told  him of the disgraceful attitude of the  authorities in this town towards the  rights of its Negro citizens and we  called for him to come down and help us  that's why he is here see chief just  obeying orders well I think y'all coming  down here tonight in this room is  nothing more than a calculated act of  provocation a calculated act of  desegregation part of my job that's what  we do what you do is disturb the peace  there is no peace here  well let's not disappoint them